and those were the days when your dad
wasn't trying to I mean I didn't have a
father but my grandfather was
that [ __ ] would pretend he he
didn't know me at a party
I'd walk up and I'd go what time are we
leaving and you look at me like he
[ __ ] never saw me before
hello everyone hola Mis Amigos you're
listening to oh my God
hola With Me George Lopez Paul
you know George is oh I'm sure he's
around here somewhere what's his name
George Robert George Lopez oh my God OMG
oh my God
are you running now yeah okay
most of the time most of the time I'm
really full of [ __ ] like I think I'm
trying to heal the world but I'm really
full of [ __ ] you know they go hey
Jordan's gonna do this he's going to do
that
come over here oh
this is for you oh
Topgolf open open this is for you or is
that just the bag
are you kidding me
no whoa look at the back look at the bag
brother
that's awesome that is what oh my God
one of his look at this the real deal
yeah
this is direct from Albert Pujols he
wore that last night it's his it's his
and that dirty what did he sign he
signed all his credits like he signed
the number he said what
two gold gloves
rookie the air oh one
3000 hits 700 homers we were there oh
that's right
all in one I mean I would find it
hard-pressed to find another one of
those
now will you wear that or you frame it
that's for you remember I told you I was
gonna get you one
that's for you man
I told him two years ago I was going to
get him one he cried the night the pool
halls uh hit the home runs uh I know
we're both at the game that night yeah
and uh a song last night and I said the
first thing I said was
I got a guy that if he knew that I was
standing here with you he'd flip right
where were you I was at the I was at
Topgolf with the Dodgers I hosted that
event with Chris Taylor yeah nice
wow that's a nice gift don't let your
dog ruin it yeah
like there's a Brady Bunch they're
playing with Joe Namath football outside
I've never even had a Jersey that had
like the race that yeah right the real
actual
wow My grandmother used to like the
Cardinals because of the bats and the
two birds we'd go to Dodger Stadium oh I
love their uniforms congratulations
that's awesome Aaron yeah there you go
and you're wearing the apropos
sweatshirt I know how much you I know
how much baseball you know I love
baseball you know we all love it yeah
but I know how much that
this means to him yeah now it's deep
it's really deep every time I get into
baseball and I love baseball too but
whenever I get in a conversation with
Aaron within a couple minutes I've I've
got to Tap Out and because you know just
and I love when guys love something that
like you can feel it you know that's a
scene but you know that's your team yeah
that is really nice job and uh I've only
given him bread
that's hilarious very good
congratulations he's very happy that you
have it too oh
he might be in here one day with his son
out with his son Albert Jr upper Jr is
quite the golfer and it was a sweet it's
nice when you see a sweet kid grow up to
be a sweet young man and you really love
something be good at it because you know
we see a bunch of
what you see a bunch of [ __ ] kids
that could give less than a [ __ ] about
anything in L.A no no
you know um are you no you know I uh
it's nice to have you here it's nice to
be here I I saw Lisa Marie Presley on
Sunday at the Elvis birthday party at
the Formosa and uh I was a huge fan of
Elvis but you know people
forget that there was you know he left
the daughter and that he was the way as
sick as he I mean maybe there's never
been anyone that's taken more drugs yeah
at any time yeah
how old was he when he died 42 42 and
his autopsy report reads like it's
like like if you were making a formica
all the ingredients that are in it uh
but
you know she didn't she looked frail you
know look it's always tiny but older and
I didn't realize she was 54 already but
but frail yeah and you know just very
kind of lethargic I thought and it's
something weird that she's gone yeah
because now you know but if but if you
know if you believe in what you believe
in like they say when you when you do
leave that your family is waiting for
you she gets to see Elvis that was her
father yeah you're like if you think
yeah you know maybe she's in a better
place
um unfortunately you know she had kids
and suffered some loss herself but right
I mean yeah
that's a sad story it's a sad yeah yeah
sorry I didn't realize he was 42. it was
only 42 years old yes I mean 42 and a
half man oh man but but rough I mean
there's a lot of she was just on TV a
couple days ago at the award service
yeah
yeah she got a chance to see all those
things that happen
um
um listen
how are we a fan of Bob Hope's
comedians growing up I was a fan of Bob
Hope but in a way that I just he was on
like ABC doing all those like specials
and stuff when I was a kid like so I
would see my grandparents and my parents
watching him like the Uso stuff and with
all the football players right all that
I did all that stuff yeah he did all
that you know
it's hard-pressed to find anybody that's
that has as many
you know would say uh uh shingles as you
do like you've written books you've
you've done movies you've done TV yeah
you've had shows you've had you've had
shows that were groundbreaking in a way
you know marriage rap and things and and
you're still right and you still I see
you here yeah like what what what is
your what do you love what's wrong with
me what yeah let's just saying you know
what do you love is almost like say what
the [ __ ] what is it what are you running
from
what is what do you love like what I
love comedy I love comedy and I like and
I'm just you know constantly been
finding ways to put it out there right
you know and stand up is the main thing
and that that's always been like
that's been the thing you could always
that you had the most control over that
you could just always go and do it no
one had to hire you to go do stand up
right so I just kept pushing that and
pushing that and then when you get these
other opportunities to come up as long
as it was comedic I would try and do it
you know I would do some straight acting
roles right that kind of thing but it
was like if I could be funny and write
books I found that path you know I can
like hosting and I can still be funny
that way you know it's all about that
and now like at this stage
I was just racing and just doing and
saying you know whatever I could do and
whatever they let me do I would do it
and then uh and now though I'm really
like you know you kick back a little bit
more and you're like yeah this is what
this is our purpose this is what we're
supposed to make things we're supposed
to make joyful things that make people
laugh yeah that's it have you done the
most episodes of podcasts are you in the
top five of guys who have done no no I
got to it late I don't know man I was
looking through your your list of
podcasts there's hundreds of them yeah I
mean I guess I had one on SiriusXM where
I was doing a whole series of interviews
right where I got like Mel Brooks and
all those kind of for a couple of years
and then and then yeah I guess it kind
of changed throughout yeah you know but
it was like you know you do these and
it's like sometimes they catch and
sometimes they don't you know there was
one podcast in the Middle where I felt
like I was just talking to myself for a
couple of years yeah know what I mean
yeah
um but yeah I just feel like that's the
thing and like now it's like
I'm on my third book I just my third
book's coming out and the stand-up
specials are coming out and it's like
it's like that's it like this feels
right this feels like the spot yeah you
know what I mean no you know I think you
know
people stay with things and then you
know culturally I think Latinos they'll
say like what are you watching and if if
you're watching for 15 seconds and it
doesn't
touch you with a color or something
they're like change that I mean wow yeah
we're the least [ __ ] devoted to
anything group of people like what do
you guys want they change that you don't
even know what it is but if they love
you
they stay with you forever I think they
stay with you forever it seems like it
right that's right there ain't no doubt
about it so before I started this I was
stuck with you but you know you know I
know how
if somebody says to me hey I saw your
[ __ ] girlfriend with some dude having
oh yeah she works with this guy I was
looking through some podcasts I saw him
in a [ __ ] iron shirt talking about
the Idaho four [ __ ] I hadn't talked to
that about the Idaho kids you said two
[ __ ] words I I don't know what's
going on the [ __ ] is always sit in the
chair well you know I mean you have to
look at it you know you have to look at
the cell phone records and the cell
times I just I just did a podcast I just
did a podcast the same one on uh the
Idaho killings you did yeah that guy
studied it right like he he's working on
his PhD and criminology you think he did
that because he was a criminal and
wanted to figure out how to do it or did
he get turned on by the I had no no idea
let's let doctors do it who doesn't he
does they I I just heard not even
[ __ ] Dexter like maybe you know yeah
dude okay I've told you that Richard
in my opinion sexually motivated crime
everything he did all sexually motivated
okay this is Richard Ramirez you know
this guy he uh I just read where they
were calling him an incel I had never
heard that word before and an incel is a
group of people on the internet that
have been rejected by women they're
celibate one they can't pick up on women
so they get pissed off with their phone
number yeah
so these incels and the way they get
back at them is to demean them embarrass
them or assault them and so this guy
like a club turn
to us an assault and the judicial term
and so I did know that term oh yeah I
know what it was yeah that's what I'm
saying yeah creepy this [ __ ]
knows creepy dudes
and so it doesn't matter how intelligent
he is if you fit that mold some
psychologist will say he was an incel
this is what he did this is why he
lashed out right and before we had
before I knew anything about this
criminal profiling [ __ ] I said I sat
down with a group of guys including one
FBI agent and I said this is what I'm
looking for I'm looking for a male a
sexual deviant who's been rejected by
women um
and that's why I thought these were all
sexually deviates and then by his own
words the guy either if you acquiesced
you lived if you didn't you died but is
it rejection I think rejection is the is
the is the foundation of any
relationship it doesn't start with
everything's yes in your mind
oh in your mind it is
sex is whatever makes you feel good
so if this guy this is you've rejected
me all this time and I shouldn't I I'm a
hey I'm working on my PhD I I don't
deserve rejection
you know look at me was he an Intel this
guy the Idaho guy he was on those sites
and stuff yeah that's what it appears
jeez so they also I mean the rejection
thing is always so weird because it's
like well it's not even are you aiming
that hot like there's someone out there
you're gonna find someone you know right
right how bad are like what what is your
I read your thing about lowering
expectations uh yeah lowering your
expectations yeah I say that all the
time so you can listen to someone tell
the same stories for the rest of your
life seven billion people out there yeah
you just find one who doesn't make you
throw up when you take your shirt off
you can find one person just lower the
bar find one person yeah
middle of the bowling alley go to the
back of the bowling there's a girl
working in the deep fryer at the bowling
alley yeah
keep breathing but it's also very
it's also much quicker to be hopelessly
I think it's quicker to have no hope
like to have no hope is here almost your
last resort you don't end up 28 years
old and thinking you have no hope just
starting out just starting out I know
but this is to me yeah that's in your
mind do you when you talk about these
people that are deviates they don't
think like you or I or Tom they've
they're focused and a lot of times it
starts with very very young trauma sure
like they're abused when they're lit
like they don't we're thinking of it
because you had a somewhat you know
normal family around you and stuff and
right
I'm assuming horrible things hadn't
happened to us but something if you're
like a two-year-old three-year-old kid
that's abused in some messed up way you
know their brain isn't wired the way the
rest of ours are you know I just
accepted Dave give me the challenge let
me go find them
how the [ __ ] why they were doing it
right let me find them and they had him
you know this guy
um they had them I think the first day
they didn't know they did they had
information but they had to make it
because the DNA it had DNA right and
they had to make it seem like they were
inept because
they had they needed weeks to get the
test back and filled the case so they I
mean this guy thought he was a
mastermind he pulled up he went around
and drove by in the morning yeah came
back driving by they had his ass from
day one really they had a tip to the
lead that way but it it took that while
you got to build your case up especially
something like that yes but they because
once you get him you could they could
have arrested him earlier but once you
arrested me only got 48 hours to [ __ ] or
get off the pot yeah so get all your
ducks in order that's exactly what they
did but they also gave different times
and made the police they'll say We'll
look like it is for seven weeks yeah
because we know what we got already so
sure when they were doing all these
things going you know you wonder why the
police haven't captured someone it's
like they couldn't come out and say we
got somebody in mind yeah we have a
hundred had to say we don't that's still
looking for tips the one thing I take my
hat off uh unlike you know the guy
either shot the gun on the you know your
actor buddy the one that shot the gun on
the Alec Baldwin Alec Baldwin okay that
Chief over there and so they got man
they started talking to the Press
talking all kinds of stuff okay and I
said then bad move they've never handled
anything they shouldn't be saying this
my hat is off congratulations to the
guys at the small Department that took
this in Moscow they didn't say [ __ ] the
public doesn't have to know yeah right
anything there's not and the minute you
tell anybody one thing
and this father the guy the father one
of the one of the victims he was so
pissed off hiring a private investigator
hiring an attorney and all he and he
doesn't realize that all he's doing is
taking time away from him and he never
stopped and they asked him to ask him to
uh
to back off and he said he did he said I
earned the right to what you understand
is his anger yeah and I hope he
understands all he did was harm you know
hurt the case yeah did this did the
killer know the victims well it looked
like he had been setting up you know he
he picked them for whatever reason yeah
he picked them and then just planned it
out you know there was plenty of
planning yeah you know that went into
this yeah but back in Augustine she had
his his car and phone and clicked and
that they got all the cell records now
right back in August but also he was a
vegan I think and he went to this
restaurant there that the girls worked
at that was a vegan restaurant oh the
only one in town and maybe might have
and agreements you look at these lady
very attractive ladies yeah and who
knows if he tried to make a move on any
of them and they rejected him so now
okay now oh God you know as a Mexican
simula you're going to pay for this
right geez what a creepo yeah ah he just
you just want to you're swimming in this
ocean with all these nut bags
bump up against them what a great case
to work though yeah you would have liked
it oh yeah yeah I've been a good case of
work do you feel it you feel it like
I feel it you ready yeah it was a good
case all that stuff right yeah
salaciousness DNA the guy left it yeah
it was the thrill of the hunt you know
yeah to be able to solve something that
everybody thinks is freaking every you
know when you break it all down it's
just also in this also in this small
community they're looking for a 2011 to
2013 white Hyundai Elantra and it's his
mom's car yeah and he doesn't come
forward and say hey I got an Elantra
meanwhile he's just driving the Elantra
around geez you know in that small area
the other thing that we're helpful is he
does you know people think oh God that
guy looks creepy that guy looks like he
looks like Harvey Milk those I mean
there's no difference he looks like it
he probably wouldn't have noticed them
yeah yeah he would have stood out
against anything are you into this thing
with this whole True Crime every a lot
of people are ah not really I don't like
it I don't know I don't you know I just
uh it it bothers me what about um what
about this catfishing and scam romances
have you you've seen any of those things
yeah where where clearly you take
somebody on Facebook who has a pretty
plain looking and then somebody sends a
picture and they're more attractive and
they say hey I love your profile you
know accept me as a friend yeah and then
you do and then you're is it low
self-esteem that when someone says babe
you're really attracted oh you know
thanks yeah then they start to talk back
and forth and
it seems pretty easy like if you know
those moments when you're like you think
back like teenage kids like right you
know you're lonely and just looking for
your place and someone all of a sudden
notices you
they said how do you not get hooked it's
got but you know and people live in
these lives these maybe I don't know if
there's a way they search people but you
know you're married you know there's
people that are married yeah that are
sending fifty a hundred thousand dollars
to somebody that's in Nigeria eventually
and they're using a picture of a guy
yeah from other social media God and
they reverse
you can post a picture and then do a
reverse on it and they can tell you who
that person is now and she's and there's
people that
you cannot convince them that that
person that they're talking to even
though they showed you the pictures is
not a real person right and at the end
they're like you know they're crying and
they say you're just going to call them
one more time it's like he doesn't the
person doesn't exist exactly yeah like
it's not you have this person in your
mind that person doesn't exist well then
who was I talking to then yeah it's like
you were talking to a picture of
somebody that was texting somebody in
Nigeria and just hiding behind the
picture but we're so lonely we just want
love so you just wanna you just wanna
you just want something yeah and I think
you look at and everybody looks at
themselves in a certain way that they
look at another person in a lower or
another way right I could never be
because it's all physical yeah it's not
somebody you talk to yeah it's not your
brain just taking it yeah it's your eyes
it's powerful stuff though I mean do you
read comments no yeah yeah do you no no
unless they're good
once in a while I'll see you oh it seems
like they like this yeah and as a rule
what don't they like but they're not
nobody's ever I don't think truly mean
to you are they no I mean at times it
depends what you're on like you know
it's not like if I would do like Joe
Rogan's podcast yeah there would and I
would say certain people would come come
out and you know because he's got such a
huge audience that it's like you know
half the people would agree with what
you're saying and then the other half
would you know want you to die of AIDS
you know what I mean it's like and uh
yeah you can't but I'm I only bring it
up because some stuff gets in your brain
these are this is just something written
this is just text you don't even know
where it's coming from these are just
words in order saying they hate you
right and you can kind of for some
reason carry that around for weeks that
sticks with you when when I was looking
when Twitter first started
I looked at a few of the stuff and you
know most of it was good and then you
start to realize that it's not good the
worst one that I ever read said I wish I
could go back in time
to when your mom was pregnant
and get a hanger
and abort you myself that's how much I
[ __ ] hate you
and you still have it in your head [ __ ]
it that's a person listen I've been
hated on for [ __ ] years that's the
one that's on the tell me let me let me
get the one from the top of the list
that's the one that I read that I was
like yeah and I you know I thought it
was funny and then it stays in your head
that's that's the topic anything
powerful maybe I didn't search around I
received I received stuff before that
said wish I was dead Richard should be
alive why am I living it's it's wrong
and I laughed I've said before I laugh
at though I don't care some 15 year old
kid is sitting back no job no no I I
don't give a [ __ ] yeah I just had got
contacted by a female from Argentina who
is a at least in comments
she's uh
I haven't seen a picture social
psychologist
social psychology well no I did see a
picture of her but I didn't know
the social psychologists
and the reason she was
writing to me was because she says
there's somebody a 15 year old kid has
started a movement out there saying that
Frank and I were full of [ __ ] we bogused
up the crime scenes we lied we did all
that [ __ ] 15 and 15 years old and
there's a movement he's got a following
now people trying to believe that I said
well I don't give a [ __ ] you know yeah
what are they gonna do the guy Richard's
already dead should we have him on yes
yes so him and his partner Franklin was
one of the maybe one of the truly
greatest detectives of of crime yeah
found uh The Night Stalker and found the
Hillside Strangler right and worked on
Manson cheese yeah yeah wow and that's
still like retired I was playing with my
partner wow he he was uh he had lost his
partner they were working on the
Hillside Strangler and his partner
retired and then he asked me and I was a
Youngster in the unit they still called
me the kid and he asked me if I'd be as
if I'd be willing to be his partner how
old are you I was only let's see
probably 33. I think that could be a
television show at the time from then
that time and it was a shocker he could
have anybody wanted he was a guru he was
the Italian Stallion what are you seeing
you and uh I don't know you you know
they asked him on on the documentary
yeah uh they asked him why did you pick
Gil he just said well he was young he
was good he spoke Spanish and
enthusiastic I thought he'd make a good
team yeah and so I remember telling my
wife hey Frank Salerno just asked me his
partner said well who's Frank I said
Frank's learner don't you understand it
yeah you know so he could add anybody
yeah and that was at a party Christmas
party about two months later he
says calls me up and say why don't you
meet me at East Sully station went down
I met him he says hey the other night at
that party you know I was in my cups and
I don't know if you remember but I asked
you if you were interested in being my
partner yeah and so I'm trying to be
cool yeah I remember I was in my cups
that night too yeah and he says well he
says I'm not in my cups now
he said uh would you still consider
being my partner
I'd consider it yeah
I said yeah that sounds good to me he
says good because I already told the
captain and it's going to be done oh wow
because that's how he became Partners
man what made him so brilliant uh he was
I I've always called him he's probably
the most consummate investigator I ever
did he's he does everything good some
people do different aspects of it yeah
he did everything good and probably as
big as asset as he's organized right and
probably my biggest deterrent is I'm not
organized you know I learned uh he was
good at a crime scene I learned to
become a good reader
I actually became I won't say a better
reader but we were on an ex we were on a
murder uh he was the acting Lieutenant
he was my boss at night we went there
and I asked him what it is we got there
and I said what do I got and he said you
gotta sell the dead or whatever they
beat the [ __ ] out and left him right
there I said okay I went up and looked
at him and this is 10 o'clock at night
on Carson uh Carson Boulevard which is a
major theater affair right in front of a
motel and right across the street from a
naval hospital Naval facility
and I went and I looked and studied and
came back I said it's not a murder it's
an accidental overdose
and he said get the [ __ ] out of here I
said it's an OD I said he went to the
naval hospital he scored his cocaine
packed his nose came across he started
staggering across the street hit the
cable that holds up the pole went down
and the gutter tried to call it that's
where he's getting all of his injuries
from I said 10 o'clock at night this
guy's in full rigor it takes full
Rigamortis takes 12 hours for full rigor
to set in from head to toe I said are
you going to tell me this guy's been
sitting out here for all these hours
traffic right in front of the hotel
nobody's called I said no
cocaine accelerate trigger ah
and the coroner's investigator got out
there and got a little
flipped the guy's Noises Off Bill's
right look he's residue up his nose he
had a partial bindle in his pocket and
so I just saw Frank this is an easy run
to send a murder nice keep us back in
the rotation we'll go I took my partner
who was a rookie brand new
drove about two blocks away we've got
two blocks away I pulled the car over
and I said yes yes because the student
that finally caught up with a master I
think he has an erection right now
now
if I went up to Frank right now and
asked him yeah I need a murder book from
1985 or your notebook you'd say okay and
he'd go get it really if somebody came
up to me and said hey I need your murder
book from 1985 I said by when he had
good luck yeah and then I'd have to go
find it yeah Frank is Extreme that that
was as big he was organized you know how
weird like
comedy made like you're just constantly
looking for what's funny right your
whole life is look at that jerk off look
at that lady that's hilarious I saw a
guy in the car
um who was just going out of his mind on
his own in his own car because
a cement truck couldn't make the turn
and the guys windows down and just like
yeah you clock that like I'll [ __ ] by
himself he's [ __ ] tormenting him he's
tortured yeah and you clock that is
comedy and like maybe you'll do
something with it who knows yeah now
when you're in crime or what when you're
in True Crime as a fan or if you're like
yourself like a great investigator do
you see the world constantly
the dangers the the evil [ __ ] that's
happening
I'm constantly just looking out for
myself I see an awful lot of stuff even
now that I I still recognize not a lot
of stuff I still go into a restaurant
yeah and I won't have my back to the
door you won't no I gotta be looking at
the door because I want to see who's
coming in who's going on so I just yes
did you know Sam Jackson was going to
try to Rob his thousands
because we're enjoying Louis Anderson
there's some people that have no idea
there's some people that'll come
I'm with a friend and the friend used to
be a cop down here to sell a go to over
there now we go in and Louie Anderson's
performing
this friend of mine she laughs just as
loud as I do so we're in there and she
gave instructions she had bucks now and
she gave me don't let the ice hit the
bottom of the glass we're having a good
old time we're laughing Louie Anderson
comes over after he's done with his set
start talking these and I said wait I'm
not from he says you're going to come
back twice no no I'm just here I was
speaking of the FBI Academy I said I'm
gone I'm back in L.A and he says hey I'm
going to be in La three weeks back he
said would you come and see me there cop
everything's cop you're on me because of
the laughter Ah that's amazing he was so
funny wasn't he so funny he was you know
there's uh there's great painters where
you know and then there's great
comedians that are painted are like yeah
the great painters that
when Louis when Louis did the tonight
for the first time and he has the little
thing and he's he's patting himself and
he's like if I don't sorry I've sweat so
much but if I don't I'll explode
you know and just them no rush to get to
the end yeah oh God look at her you know
all those things that so good I saw
some I was doing a gig in Northern
California and it was a weird comedy
channel on yeah in the hotel I hadn't I
hadn't seen it but they were just
running old stand-up and I came back
from my show and it was still going on
and it was all like Paula Poundstone and
and Louis set came on and it's on TV and
you and he's starting out and he's first
two jokes Miss he's bombing
and but and you see it as a comedian you
can see it in his eyes like uh oh you
know yeah yeah but never loses his cool
just a pro kicks back just changes his
register a little bit by the Andy's
killing it was so it was so like just to
watch a pro you know what I mean like
that yeah thing with that camera right
up close he was impressive so and to do
The Tonight Show was
I mean as big as but then those guys
showed not an ounce of nerves yeah that
was just amazing I know I know you know
Eddie Murphy Shan lean you carry yeah uh
Allen's Alan Robin Williams yeah you
know it was so much bigger God it was
way different much bigger yeah yeah yeah
I love gum I I just love comedy guys
yeah
who did you like uh grow you're Greek to
right no Italian oh they say Greek
though no no Italian Papa p-a-p-a what
was your father like uh my father's
still around oh God bless him he's uh
we're uh Sicilian
and uh he's pretty Sicilian you know
he's got a little bit of a
he's he's got a little he was growing up
when he's growing when you were growing
what did he what did he had were they
would wear a t-shirt sideburns yeah yeah
tight shirts big arms big big gorilla
arms yeah yeah grown a motorcycle wow
man but grew up in like Suburban New
Jersey but he didn't belong there Paul
rizzi's dead yeah yeah man yeah really
nice like love kids love family loved
all that stuff but he was tough like you
knew he still like my you know Fortune
them yeah yeah awesome yeah he came by
the show and uh she just picked it up
immediately like oh your dad's a badass
I didn't know your dad was a badass yeah
he could still you can still yeah yeah
we were at a family reunion we do a
Christmas thing I I have a this dinner
every Christmas and we get everybody all
the Italians together in northern New
Jersey and keeps the family together and
and all my cousins that are my age are
waiting for the day because my father
will shake your hand and he'll make
bring you to your knees like he'll
squeeze it so hard that he brings you to
your knees and still and now and like
guys are in their 40s and 50s still
trying to hurt his hand and he can't do
it he stole the claw yeah
well I just walked in yeah exactly and
what did he what did he like when he was
growing up what did he was he into he
football football and working he was one
of seven kids they had no money and uh
so they were all working really young
and uh he worked really hard and played
football he was like the
captain of these of all his teams and
state championships and he was tough
he's just tough he's just like you know
you grow up and just
was he hiding was could it be warm could
he could he tell you he loved you and
yeah uh yeah later on yeah later on you
know and uh it was almost like a
generational thing it's like right they
had to kind of hear that it was okay to
say all that stuff and but he was very
warm he's very like
but but tough like very strict very
strict and we had that common Bond of
you know football and he coached me my
whole career oh wow and then and then
riding bikes at the same time together
and uh yeah but it was you know like
it wasn't like it's crazy
that's your football coach and you ride
motorcycles together yeah but it was
like you know a dad like it wasn't it's
not like the cool La dads like yeah you
and hanging out like oh like we're
friends right it's like I know this is
your father yeah yeah yeah and and those
were the days when your dad wasn't
trying to I mean I didn't have a father
but my grandfather was
that [ __ ] would pretend he
didn't know me at a party
I walk up and I'd go what time are we
leaving and you look at me like he
[ __ ] never saw me before
he looked like this
was he trying to bust a move on somebody
else's [ __ ] right guys
you look at me like I don't know who the
[ __ ] you are why are you why are you
talking to me what time are we going to
take off
that's hilarious I mean and now it's all
about
I mean I I don't know I mean listen it
should be all about love because you
never know but it wasn't I love you I
love every day I love you I love you I I
love you never see you later I love you
I mean yeah I just hung up with my
mother on the way here
and uh
and she doesn't say I love you all the
time you know like my wife and her
parents like they were always every
every phone call my wife when she's
talking to her or anybody yeah I love
you I love you I love you I love you I
love you and I was like is our family
weird are we cold like because we don't
really say it all that often I never on
the phone would say it was my dad like
it's a couple shots but my mother when I
was on my way here she just said goodbye
and didn't didn't say I love you and I
didn't say I love you and I was like
that's kind of cool
because when they do say it it has
weight to it right you know what I mean
I didn't my dad
even told me I never said he he comes so
I would say he was proud of you because
no yeah you did one time
and then my mom said oh it took 27 years
alive and then now you're gonna say
you're proud of him yeah and he said no
I was proud of him uh
for all these years he says but not
telling him was part of making him a man
oh yeah so he was like yeah and so put
it on purpose I'm sitting there saying
my dad's quick on his feet that's a good
one dad and then I found out years later
it was true well after he was gone I
went to his yard uh the construction
yard where he used to uh work at and
they said hey your career's boy and I
said yeah and hi pleased to meet you
I've heard your names and and they said
well man your dad was really proud of
you yeah from the time he went in the
Army then when you became a couple
forget about it you know it no you
didn't know it did not know it you
thought he was rejecting you I didn't
think he was rejected just didn't know
how to say it right but because of that
there is not since my kids grew up now
my I have 51 47 and 44. and there is a
day that goes by if I see him that I
don't say I love you yeah do you know
what that is Tom I mean I look at you I
think I almost look at you almost like a
as a scholar of relationships do you
know what that is in somebody that they
wouldn't say whether it would be
conceited I don't want it to go to your
head that's my grandmother would say I
don't want you know I want you to start
thinking you know to start getting
conceited about what right exactly yeah
about you know and
I grew up alone with and I watched this
[ __ ] box and I became more than what
I what we all saw in that box and they
[ __ ] never said to me my grandma was
around when I first show started you did
it uh-huh I knew you could know you
didn't audit but not a [ __ ] you know
George you're really something am I what
I do now we used to watch [ __ ] TV
and you would try to make me laugh and
you became the [ __ ] guy on the team
not nothing nothing be watching TV
[ __ ] silent
[ __ ] not a word
hey Grandma yeah show right there
um
so what did that do to you as a dad I
just man I don't I like wait did you I
just think it kept me disconnected
uh-huh you know my therapist would say
you got a rope
and a lot of people's rope is connected
you got yours and here it doesn't
connect so you got two pieces of rope
that don't touch in the middle and who's
on the other side of the Rope whoever
your family like your kids and
everything really Matt I'll get along
with you know mine and I are doing the
show but yeah
um
you know we didn't talk for years but
also you start to realize
in the one family member that I do that
I do love Yeah am I gonna not talk to
her because of all the [ __ ] that's going
on with me and her mom or whatever and I
said no not really yeah like it's the
first time that I ever went to go get a
relationship that to me was worth it as
opposed to just you know I don't there's
whole parts of my family that I don't
talk to yeah yeah they're not very good
people I would say allegedly not very
good people yeah weren't good to my
grandmother who was their mother and
grandmother and with at the time that my
grandmother passed I made some pretty
hard decisions but they weren't mine
they were really my grandmothers I mean
nobody would believe it but you know my
grandmother like a lot of old people sat
at home yeah and no one would come and
see her and I'd go and see her and take
her to the market and come and visit
with her and occasionally they would but
they would take things you know yeah
there was always a motive and she said
to me when I pass I don't I don't want
uh this I don't want that I said well
you know it's not going to be very
popular I don't care because I sit here
alone and nobody he comes to see me and
the last thing even in passing she
didn't want to even think of herself in
a place where you could go and cry and
then know her thinking all these people
are crying about me nobody came to see
me I don't even want to consider that
when I'm gone right but she said I don't
want to uh I mean gravestone like she
wanted to be cremated yeah um yeah yeah
I want to be cremated you do yeah that's
not because a friend of mine told me he
said Gil he says come on are you gonna
do something just think about when you
die your friend's gonna have to carry
your fat ass in that too [ __ ] heavy
so I told the wife but you know it's
like when you go sandwich they hollow
out the bread yeah they take all the
stuff off yeah you'll be like you'll be
like a bird you'll be a baby bird I'm
caring I've been a Paul Bearer so many
times I've carried skinny people [ __ ]
things are heavy the coffin alone yeah
[ __ ] they're heavy so yeah put me in
it put me in a nerd I've done I've been
a Paul Bearer where somebody went oh you
look back at the [ __ ] people oh no
it's like a [ __ ] play it's like an
airplane you're like oh the wings are
[ __ ] tipped they're like hey you go
like that you're like oh and you're like
grab a hold of it man yeah but I feel
like I feel like it's kind of
generational like we like just that
we're even talking about it you know
three grown men yeah talking about
saying I love you to your children and
and your brothers and whatever it's like
you would never talk about that a
generation ago you just dealt with it
and swallowed it you know it's and then
when you died you fell apart at the
grave site yeah I didn't I not when my
mom not my dad I cried like a good thing
when I had to put my dog down uh I
missed my Molly I I don't maybe because
I was around death so much at work I
understood natural human death right so
I didn't cry when I've lost a sister my
mom and my dad and
cried a couple of copper the guy that
broke me in on homicide I cried at his
funeral yeah
in Georgia I'll try to drop a half he
just said he cries all the time it's not
the big stuff yeah I I do get uh yeah I
I get him do you cry all the time I
don't cry all the time I I get choked up
especially like if I got two daughters
so anything on TV with a father and the
daughters like if I watch your show I'll
cry even if you're it's funny I'd just
like to see a father daughter I'll get
choked up interesting huh yeah but I
don't let it out too much because
because I don't cry all the time that
when I do cry it's just a big mess it's
like too much like I can't stop it's
interesting to think what is what is our
psychology that that is something that
you could be looking at and you look the
other way and you start immediately that
is what triggers you yeah it surprises
you right right it's a catch off Gordon
yeah the day we convicted Richard of
everything I came home that night and I
got in bed yeah but also you had you
asked your family not to be
to leave the house because while he was
out there there was a chance that
back then those criminals would show up
and he knew where he it turned out he
knew where I lived yeah we found
Footprints I mean really so we we had
cops sitting on my house all the time
but this time my wife was gone right so
we finally convicted his ass and I come
home that night and I get in bed don't
say anything to the wife the wife has
never seen me cry yeah and I got in bed
and I started crying like a baby wow
this is the relief and she just leaned
over put her hand on me and said it's
okay your dad's with you wow I think she
did that just to put you over the
[ __ ] disease
exactly it's
it's crazy your dad is with you yeah the
day before my dad died we're at the
hospital and I told everybody clear the
room
and I thought I said dad I got to talk
to you I got to tell you something and I
grabbed his hand
and I said I just got to tell you
I love you I had never said I love you
to my dad it wasn't in the culture I
guess yeah yeah so I grabbed his hand I
said I love you
and he's put his hand on top mine he
says
mule me too
say I love you uh me too
what George and he's already going he
said me too he ain't gonna say I love
you I know I can spit it out man it's
like I told my sister the next day
[ __ ] spit it out he died that night
and early in the morning and next day
we're at my mom's house
and I told my sister I said I wish I'd
heard my dad say I love you I just I
know he did I just wish
yeah and she came in about 30 minutes
later she said you know you question
your dad's love
I said no I just wanted to hear him say
he said well you question so I'm going
to show you something
we're going through his stuff and in his
closet he had a metal box I don't know
if he didn't trust them every single
with all the love letters of the to the
Dad wrote to the other guy
she had a metal box in that metal box
he had ten thousand dollars for my mom
just right away
he had deed to the house all the
insurance papers every important Doc in
me he had he had in that metal box she
says and look what he had it and it was
a she opened it up there was a newspaper
article
and the headlight it was about me there
was a picture on me about me helping
start an orphanage when I was in Vietnam
asking for help she says that's how much
he loved you right so then I started
crying all over again yeah but but he he
never did but I know he I know and they
just didn't have it they didn't they
were taught to not do that to not show
it especially as a man you were like how
how are uh
how was your wife your wife did stand-up
tuition performer as well right yeah
yeah she was when I met her she was a
stand-up at comic strip and uh how was
that was it was it an easy like when you
saw each other was it an easy do you
feel good with her yeah yeah immediate
but we and then we realized uh like I
met her
and I was with Ian bag you know Ian yeah
oh yeah Ian was there and it was like
during the day in the comedy club which
is always weird yeah and uh and we met
and there was just something was there
wow it just and she wanted to be in the
sketch group that I was in and then she
left and Ian was like what the hell was
that what what just happened between
like he saw it oh wow and it turned out
we went to the same kindergarten a year
apart so and I moved one town over in
like third grade so we had the same
summer jobs in high school we had same
parties we never met until we were in
the comic strip so there was this whoa
it was almost like family you know what
I mean like yeah we just knew each other
we knew we had we knew everything about
each other like insist yeah yeah the
good kind
the
but it is like you're running parallel
like you you don't you don't you're
you're not it's just you're living you
guys are having fun it's not and there
you are kind of around each other I
think that's the whole time right
kindergartners you know and
we worked at the hotel I was a busboy
and she was like a cocktail waitress and
yeah it was crazy you know I I I I could
never connect I mean I never saw a
connected relationship growing up and uh
I spend I mean you know I spend a lot of
time alone not that it's bad but um
it's funny to think that what you were
concerned about at 12
at 61. I'm still concerned about it he's
been the one the disconnect from in
relationships right because I never saw
I never saw a healthy one I really saw I
mean yeah I only saw
I only saw trouble right you know and
that just those were just the people
that were around me so then you expect
that and then I all the guys I grew up
with
got married within
four-year period from [ __ ] 18 to 22
those guys were all [ __ ] married
right and I was seeing somebody but I
wasn't going to get married I wanted to
do this yeah yeah you know I wanted I
was doing this in high school right but
you know right weeks before we graduated
right nobody ever thought that I mean
you look back at San Fernando High and
you look back at what this has become
yeah nobody saw this
right it's weird it really does come
down to like what you're raised with
yeah you know I would call you back to
the high school dude
Mexican done good no no I don't think so
and you know what's interesting is I
think of myself going back to the high
school
like you know I give toys to the
elementary school every year they did it
when I was growing up yeah 1970 through
the 70s 73 and then
um I woke up when my show was on like in
2005 and I just said I wonder if they
still do that that called over there
they're like what year did you graduate
from here I said 73 I go joy it's 2005
and I was like it is [ __ ] like to me
yeah the time is just left closer yeah
it doesn't feel like it's that like when
I think about high school like we're
talking about right now
and being 18 versus going over there if
they did call me I'm 61. yeah
going over the 61 year old and walking
on the baseball field where I was when I
was 15 16 17 18. yeah
is is just the field is named after me a
nice because you know I bottom
championship rings
15 years ago nice and it's been that
long so it's like it's weird it's more
for people I don't know than for people
that I know right yeah like Aaron but
you have that in you like it's it's
like you have you could just tell from
your performing and everything that
there's that there's something there's
love in you but you just never learn the
rules of how to do it that's right it's
weird he's never told me he loves me he
told me did he if you open up his glove
compartment there's an article about you
there's a in his Clubhouse but you
always have a great affinity for you man
I always thought you were really funny
oh thanks and you know I always thought
that you were really very disciplined
and a hard worker very creative and
really very good like even sitting with
you now is like I just was looking at
the things that you had done and yeah of
course I mean you just just but you were
like you were you were already one of
the guys when I when I showed up and it
was like you know we met I think when
your show was on NBC years ago yeah yeah
that's right yeah you had a great card
and what what why do you think that that
show didn't go you think that show
didn't go because uh we hadn't we it
seemed like we were on the fast path to
getting on the air I mean then Jeff
Zucker left NBC
and a new president came in and Jeff
Zucker loved the show and this new guy
just got handed this mid-season show and
was like not into it
and then he put Steve Carell on it to
play my boss I didn't even have a
workplace oh and they they were trying
him out for the office oh
and then they made a deal with him to go
on the office like while he was on our
show man so it was just this President
just wasn't into it it was just one of
those who was that guy um Kevin Riley
yeah
yeah he went over to Fox I think it was
funny how that's how you just get played
like it's a it's a chess board to them
and you they just move people around
yeah they own you you gotta get lucky
you got to say yeah you got to get lucky
yeah that [ __ ] has to kind of all line
up and um it's sad yeah it's a bit it's
a bit of a [ __ ]
um
what is it like um I understand it's a
business I wouldn't say demolition derby
I would say it's a bit of a
of a like is it a gamble everything's a
gamble it's a gamble it's a heartless
business they're they're playing it's
hard you you know with your your futures
this on their hunches
that's what they're doing there is no
science but you could have a fan like
you could have Jeff Zucker be a fan and
then him leave and then someone else
comes in and they're not a fan and
everything you felt and you knew was
good yeah is pulled out from under you
and you talk to I talked to Phil
Rosenthal and he was in the process he's
amazing of watching CBS pickup shows and
it's like you're here in La making these
shows and you have all your Executives
and you think this is and they all love
it and then in New York when it comes
time to do it on the top of the
skyscraper there are these guys that
have no idea how hard you've been
working who you are what's going on and
the way they make decisions it really
makes it seem like oh we shouldn't be
that invested in it because it's kind of
out of here that's the greatest thing
about being a stand-up is that
the show was canceled quickly after the
all that shuffling
and I was like oh [ __ ] you know like I
got canceled but within two months
I was driving right back onto NBC lot
parking and going to do stand up on The
Tonight Show and that's when I realized
oh okay
it was long as I'm a comedian you have
it's up to me yes all that stuff about
getting your show on that stuff's crazy
who knows
but as long as I'm really funny and can
walk in and be the funniest person in
the room
I can have a shot currency yeah that
that's currency but I remember hearing
about you because I was when I first
started headlining and we went to the uh
Tempe Improv in Arizona yeah and they
talked about when you would come through
because I'm nervous I'm not no one's
coming to see me yet right I hardly even
have a headlining act right this is my
person and just the legend of what you
used to do in that room that was a
killer I think a killer you would just
crush the and they all talked about the
roof coming off okay I don't know what
the [ __ ] I was doing but I was crushing
I think I was always uh engaging like I
like even the guys in 79 Joy Gainer and
fox and those guys uh would see me at
The Comedy Store in Westwood yeah on the
third time
I just got
the third time I was standing by the
side of the stage me and Ernie my friend
Ernie
and Joey Gainer says you're next and
it's like 8 50 on a Monday morning and a
Monday night and it sold out in the
summer of 79 was just a beautiful time
for comedy yeah
um
79 Richard Pryor Letterman well uh Howie
Mandel
um all those guys yeah
um um Shan lean those guys I mean the
variety shows so a lot of guys you know
dressing those guys all were and uh I
was like
you're he's like you're next I wasn't
supposed to go on until after 11 maybe
huh
and I think he just moved me into a
place where you I could not do poorly
even though I didn't know what I was
doing
it was just like you went up there and
yeah started laughing you started
talking and you just it just were buying
it three minutes four minutes yeah and
me and me you know I record everything
on a recorder and then me and Ernie ran
outside and we were run up and down the
street and I think in my life what I was
I was uh
18 I just turned 18. and I think in my
life it was the first time that I ever
was excited for something good
with just just something good happened
that just happened and he and I were
running up and down looking for a place
to listen to the tape
and we were running
it felt like my feet weren't touching
the ground wow and we just sat across
the street was a
office but it was like a like a you know
when somebody had it looked like a house
but they were a dentist yeah and it was
connected to it yeah we sat on the stoop
there and listened to it like nine times
in a row and I think it was like the
first it's amazing
thing I that you felt was good yeah and
it was like an infusion of it I mean it
didn't change me yeah as a person
but it's still a grind but it at least
gave me something to look to the Future
at least spark something where I thought
well maybe there is your place instead
of having that moment come seven years
later when you finally kill yeah I
killed the third time so it gave me
something to be like what [ __ ] I can
yeah I can kill at some point yeah I've
already done it well guys it don't
really do it did it take a dip at all or
did it
um it took a dip yeah just as you were
kind of figuring and then I was a
quitter so that I had to real realize
that that you quit I would stop and quit
and go back and quit oh really yeah
really and then I had I didn't know that
because you didn't like nothing ah
oh really yeah what do you mean like it
got too much and the pressure was so
nervous yeah I was shy it was it was
really who was your friend my friend
Ernie Ariana passed away in the Navy
last April but that was like a bit of my
muse you know like that guy yeah was
spawning we would watch Comedy and he
had older brothers and he was the guy
who turned me on to
really rock concerts he turned me onto
the guitar turned me on to Richard Pryor
and turned me on to being a comedian so
yeah those four things that I still do
today yeah were none of them were my
idea wow I was just the guy that said
you ought to let's do this we gotta go
and do this were they supportive the
other guys that were around because you
were so young and they were no not
really not really no and I remember
going to The Comedy Store on on Sunset
and being on stage at eight and at 805
being outside on the [ __ ] sidewalk
and people are starting to come in and
then by 8 30 it's full and then when I'm
in there there's probably seven people
yeah I mean yeah but but you were I
didn't know you're such a good performer
like that the the I remember you
remember when we did the gig together in
um Clint Eastwood's uh the volunteers
yeah for the golf thing that's right
and they it's they they do this uh
Pro-Am golf thing and the night before
the the thing for all the volunteers
that work it's like thousand people they
they put on a show and it's
Michael Bolt and and Kenny G Kenny G and
uh yeah and all these great people and
uh and they're and they're telling
everybody you got to be clean you got to
be really clean for this audience
because you know it's all the volunteers
and George is closing the show he's
gonna go up last and they've sat through
probably two hours of stuff and I
remember you just walk I just because I
was new to all of it I couldn't believe
I was even on the show and I'm just
watching George like just kind of like
you can feel the energy kind of like
building up and they're like you've got
to be clean gotta clean and he goes up
and he goes what the [ __ ] are you people
doing
and just women because he knew that he
knew the people he knew the culture he
knew the whole thing and you just
destroyed it it was so powerful
so great I think when you're last you
could do that but you don't want to you
wouldn't want to put that in the middle
well you kind of had to do it yeah
because you're so tired forever yeah
yeah and you guys went up and just but
just but as a young comic watching you
just kind of like watching a race car
kind of like start revving its engine
before it's gonna take out like
remembering and you could just see him
kind of like walking back and I was just
I was like a sponge I was just soaking
all of it in but also you know I I
watched you know uh
you and you don't really know I mean I
didn't have a guys I went with really
but then you figure out what kind of
style are you gonna what kind of style
are you gonna be like what energy you're
gonna bring in yeah it was so counter to
the way I I mean everything's contrary
to the way we are like I'm not
you know an outgoing person for the most
part but then you know if if you know
I've been around so long that people
would think like yeah hey man [ __ ]
what's up you're like hey what's going
on dude you're all right yeah yeah I'm
good yeah George Lopez huh yeah
all right you're like yeah dude all
right cool yeah where people be like
what's your [ __ ] problem what's my
problem I have a problem you know but
now I think people realize that there
can be there's not just one person
there's yeah a few a few different
personalities which I I think now do you
have comedy friends that have gone the
distance with you
not really yeah no not really do
long-term friends just in general uh
yeah yeah guys I went to high school
with I still I still talk to you yeah
but also you know when
things don't go your way you absorb all
because your name is on the you absorb
it all yeah
like you know the first show
did great because it created it made
history it was never syndicated Latino
show them even even if you look at like
Desi Arnaz was it was Cuban and then
Freddie Prince's hunger weekend Puerto
Rican Hungarian and then how much
Chicano so I'm the only Chicano right
and you know it's still on 20 years
later every day and nobody celebrates
that but when it got canceled they'll be
like ah what happened
yeah mad because it's your name yeah and
all that stuff so you realize I know
when you get a bite like a pit bull when
you get a bite I'm gonna hold on for as
long as even with this one with Mayan
yeah it's really my Mayan is really
I think my daughter mine is really
the the the breath of fresh air in in
that show because nobody really I never
really even talked about my daughter
right and then you see her and she's got
some mannerism but she's her own person
and she's good yeah nationally good
people send me a message today I don't
really follow shows I'm not that kind of
person but I love you I love your
daughter yeah you know you're like I can
tell just from the just from one one act
I know man yeah [ __ ] great man and
you know she she was at that party with
me that Elvis party and yeah it's cool
and you know I drank and she the last
thing I remember her saying was I'm
getting a little bit buzzed and then you
know I go pray you know and very
supportive and very loving and yeah just
Bas Lerman you know came over and Austin
Butler and they're talking to her and
you're just like man this kid is really
amazing the next level of you know
you're gonna I used to be what a what a
what a Porsche look like you know it's
kind of a little bit of a bug eye and
now you see it it's this [ __ ] thing
that you know you can't just take the
rims off you have to go take it to a bed
that I think that for the Lopez that's
where I think my legacy will be in yeah
in my in Mayan has it has it changed
your relationship oh yeah yeah yeah it's
you know
um
when you cause a lot of pain in a family
that
there's really no you know when you try
to cheer somebody up in the book listen
man [ __ ] you man you you just don't
think you can come in here and just make
me laugh and and have all that [ __ ] go
away so you have to have somebody that
had an open heart and even her mom and
her have had Open Hearts where yeah if I
was willing to
repair they were willing to be repaired
right where mostly I would just say [ __ ]
[ __ ] those people man yeah you know and
the way I grew up they were just you
would just not see anybody anymore right
it's worked out yeah right it's worked
out like that
it's interesting I remember when uh
when uh I had something I was up for
something and didn't get it this is back
to like the comedians you know
uh and I came back to the comedy seller
and uh maybe it was a canceled show and
Manny who was the owner of the comedy
seller he said I heard uh I heard your
your show got canceled I was like yeah
he goes you made a lot of comedians very
happy
[Laughter]
you know what I used to what I remember
is going to a meeting maybe at Paramount
and then going to the office and behind
them there was a
bookcase with all scripts lined up and
they would write the name of the show in
The Binding of the script with a marker
and I remember sitting there looking at
the names and none of those [ __ ]
shows made it yeah and then you're
sitting there thinking all right well
why would why would I make it but then
also
why wouldn't I make it is what I started
to really think is is you look at all
those and names you realize and things
that you heard that didn't work and they
put them back there and then you start
to think
well why why can't I yeah you know why
why wouldn't I yeah I mean I love
Richard Pryor my grandmother did not
like Richard Pryor and I played that
[ __ ] live in Long Beach a thousand
two five thousand times in the house
yeah and my grandmother would go should
be like
you don't get tired of that [ __ ]
black guys like I love a grandpa
you know that she's passing by and then
cut to 2007 I spoke at his funeral whoa
like I eulogized them whoa really
standing there and you're trying to tell
your grandmother why you think this guy
is incredible wow and she's like I can't
imagine you watching this [ __ ] thing
again
[Laughter]
wow man that's it's really I mean really
something man yeah those things are just
you know Freddie Prinze I I stole
Freddie Prince headstone in [ __ ]
1978. it'd been dead a year you what I
stole this headstone from Forest Lawn
you stole it
what
I used to go over there and just sit
there man that notice it was a little
loose kind of entirely
and then I what like the plaque yeah I
was like going like this because I guess
it's a little bit no
and then I was telling this story and
then
maybe a year and a half later in the
summer I go to the to the market with my
grandmother and there's a globe there
that always had that alien kid you know
the black and white he had a picture of
Freddie Prince mom at the bottom and it
said grave robbers are trying to steal
my son's body
I got
[Laughter]
buy it and I she bought it for about one
and said it said that the headstone was
missing and yeah that was like it was me
do you still have it
I have to find it I have it I have a
chance somewhere but you know how I did
to repay him is when my show was coming
close to the 100th episode and Johnny
Grant the former mayor you know the
mayor of Hollywood that little guy he
said hey I went to Steve Edwards uh star
ceremony and he's like I think it's time
we we put you in the walk I said I'm not
going in I still remember I'm not going
if Freddie Prince goes in oh he looks at
this assistant I think Freddie is in and
I said I don't think he's in and she
said uh I don't know and he said well
let us check and then
we'll call you back and I think within
days they called and said he's not in
but if you want him to be in
we'll you can sponsor him in and then
it's ten thousand dollars and then you
can have the ceremony we'll do the
ceremony I said I'll do it and I I I
stole the headstone yes but in 2006 I
put him in the Hollywood Walk of Fame Ah
that's great well I think he belonged
but he didn't steal it he didn't belong
in Forest Lawn yeah but he belonged on
the Walker and that was a painful I mean
even though Freddie Jr is still alive
it's it's yeah it's like for me it's
like I didn't know the game yeah but
it's just you know your idol that's more
than an idol that just seems just so
yeah that's my idol like an hire thing I
never met him but what that show did for
me yeah was it it changed my it changed
my life yeah my life with Mayan changed
my life of all these actors and it
changes
yeah man oh my God that's why they said
well they go Lopez versus Lopez what
what would you've called it I said I
want to call it Chica and the man
Lopez didn't work I Gotta Give a eulogy
tomorrow you do yeah for who for what
the for uh an old friend of mine
retirement center from the Department
who's a long time old friend beautiful
guy check this out beautiful couple him
and his wife they were married 60 years
they they were just sweethearts yeah and
they they were good people and
he got diagnosed with cancer she had
Parkinson's disease in the end and he
says I'm not leaving this world I'm not
going before her I'm going to be here
until she goes she passed away on a
Monday
in less than 24 hours he passed away on
Tuesday man
how does that happen he just told about
I'm not leaving before her can you wow
can you tell God that I boy he did
something so they're having the services
tomorrow for both of them whoa and I'll
be I'll be doing the eulogy tomorrow wow
so God bless him no laughing you're
gonna cry you know we all know the end
the Buddhists say we all know the end
and they say well you know I want to go
to heaven when I die and the Buddhists
say why don't you make this heaven so
that you don't have to wonder if you're
going to go to heaven
make this nice your Heaven that's true
you know do the things that you want to
do and laugh and yeah and do drink a
little too much and and hold your wife
and go places and watch the sun go down
yeah you're pushing it you know
carry over the threshold
you know they don't do that [ __ ] anymore
in the old days you could carry your
wife over the threshold now
the threshold your spine will shoot out
of your [ __ ]
[Music]
ready to throw those balls come on up
here baby
man right
I've seen people you know now everything
except he's got a phone in the camera
I've seen guys you can look at carrying
the Bride of the threshold those dudes
that go head first man into just the
cement of their of their new house
they're like come on baby the smoke it
goes down it gets up he's cut his
forehead carried his wife over you know
some some traditions that yeah you know
what do you Aspire for your kids like
what do you what do you hope your kids
become I just want to be good people
yeah just kind of enjoy their lives be
good people yeah help other people you
know yeah that's really it I just want
them to be because I feel like that's
that's kind of the that's kind of it
right is I mean you know that was what
all of us that would try to they would
try to point you into a behavior like
hey come come down
quietly you know you know you sit there
quiet and you're trying to control your
yeah I don't think you can do that to a
kid now you just you just want them to
be like you want them to be good people
and yeah you give them some guidance I
mean there is that part where you know I
feel like we're not
people aren't parenting enough in a way
like you can still tell your
your kids right from wrong and right I
think you have to step up that way but
as far as like what they want to be and
do as long as they're passionate and
they're kind of they wake up in the
morning want to do it you know and be
useful I think uh I think that's it you
know and just be good people other than
that you know what's the concept of
breaking bread do you bake bread I do I
bake bread a lot yeah yeah you'll come
on my podcast
how did you you know I still I do really
big big bread yeah you take a lot of
bread I do believe that there's things
that people and every and all people
should be doing with themselves but they
don't whether they love to draw whether
they love to sew whether they love an
instrument or they love something that
they're not doing yeah wow those are my
breads yeah
incredible sorry to interrupt and how
and how did and how did that come about
I just started uh a friend of mine was
in a writer's room on a show that I was
working on and uh but did you have it in
your system did you feel I was I could
cook I was I love cooking you know like
I said we come to this big Italian
family yeah I like cooking and I always
I enjoy that and like you know giving to
other people and that kind of thing and
then my friend turned me on to how this
Bread is made this natural way to make
bread with sourdough starter and this
whole thing and and uh
I just my daughter gave me a sourdough
start that's like yeast it's like a
living thing yeah yeah wow and uh she
gave it to me for Christmas she got it
started and I made my first Loaf and
something about it it's very close to
Comedy it's like you can you're by
yourself you can kind of get good at it
but you could also fail at any month at
any minute you got to kind of like
there's a pace to it and then it just
fills the house with that smell of you
know fresh baked bread
we bought uh I was like a little kid I
wanted an outdoor pizza yeah my
grandkids come down and go swimming and
so we're always ordering pizzas you know
yeah I said why are we putting all those
well let's make something so I got it
this last some lessons it was hot
terribly hot outside so you didn't want
to spend time up yeah then it got all of
a sudden it turned cold overnight so we
had made pizzas we just made some the
other night last week yeah and
the wife didn't want me to buy it it's
gonna be another toy you're using one
yeah yeah yeah we bought it
and we made him a couple of weeks ago
what does it look like though
it's uh it's called the uni and and it's
it's a nice Pizza Oven gets up to 700
degrees or something yeah I can make
like a little metal thing yeah okay 12
inch pizzas in there less than two
minutes put them in their terminal a
little bit come on yeah they're good
yeah and everybody loved them everybody
we made them a couple of weeks ago
and she loved it because everybody even
the grandkids got involved in putting
the the sauce and the pepper making
their own it was a family-oriented thing
exactly uh the sauce I bought from an
Italian place an Italian restaurant nice
we get the the dough out there get it
all up put the sauce on there get the
cheese on there pepperoni put it on yeah
and the little the six-year-old yeah you
know actually this is the way you do it
Papa yeah that's great he's having fun
and it was a good thing the next day the
hardest part was you put the pizzas in
there if you go to a regular pizza party
you look at them they stick that thing
in there and they turn them around a
little bit
Yeah so I had purchased when I bought
this a small pizza peel especially made
for turning couldn't find it couldn't
find it so we're Mickey Mouse I got this
thing and put a rag in your hand
two days later
Blackstone has come out with a brand new
one oh yeah yeah an oven an oven
you can make 16 inch pizzas 16 inches
gets up to 900 Degrees on the inside and
and it's got a thing that spins on the
inside so you no longer so I told the
wife she's all excited because we just
had the family I said look at this or
normally she'd say oh you're full of
[ __ ] yeah we bought this one and she
said we'll get it
nice so it's coming it'll it'll arrive
tomorrow the smaller one yeah we'll give
to my daughter now we're gonna make it
for the boys and I can't wait it really
is something right now yeah and the wife
didn't want she didn't block because of
his family stuff that's right she liked
it because it was just for you she
wouldn't have been here what did your
daughter think when she bought you that
thing that you think that potentially
like you like to cook yeah yeah I don't
know she you know you basically put
flour and water in a dish and let the
yeast just fly in and start eating it
and then it becomes it starts to bubble
and then you keep feeding it and it
becomes this thing and then you now
you've trapped the yeast and she just
shows to me at Christmas morning just
gives me a bowl filled with this snot
and uh yeah she's she you know because
it's become a thing like people know me
for breaking bread and uh but it does
look they do look great oh they're great
I'll get you yeah for sure yeah and uh
and she's like who knew just from her
giving me that gloop that I'd be talking
about baking bread on yeah yeah how many
different types of bread do you bake
um they're all like sourdough based
which is it's just kind of the thing but
some of them aren't sour and I've got
like four or five different
combinations of stuff it's great
jalapeno and cheddar is a really good
one yeah that's really good
I'll buy that at the Mexican maybe a
podcast I think that that's the one and
then all right you got it Aaron clock
that but I think that it is really
something to find sure to have something
that pulls you away from something that
can be very uh singular yeah you know
right exactly and you know when I
started writing the books
that was like it was it meant I was home
I was working but you're taking these
little breaks to go then deal with the
doe come back to writing go deal with
the doe come back to right like it kind
of fit that kind of writing schedule
yeah yeah it's nice I feel like it's
yeah I feel like it's uh I feel good
about what you were saying like I can
feel it inside the yeah yeah you'll feel
really good when you're eating it yeah
in this oven I don't know what do you
what temperature do you put your bread
in 500 500 now see yeah because these
ovens they are they also show they make
bread in them oh yeah as well yeah now
that's the thing like a nice
a nice oven King really hot
that's what you need for the pizzas
that's what you need for other baguettes
and those things too you need a little
more heat you know I don't I don't think
that we
I think the East Coast really gets into
those things like freshly baked bread
like there's places out here that do
that and I don't think if you're going
to the
a French baguette or a Sourdough Thing
versus somebody getting
some already oral wheat wheat bread I
think more people should get the bread
that's baked yeah yeah that instead of
the things that you're sure you know
delivered by a truck sure all these
places are still they're still baking
all the grocery stores look at this
Tabernacle I know no it is yeah and
that's the thing it's like everyone's
started swearing off bread that you
shouldn't eat bread and you're gonna get
fat from eating bread it's because we
weren't eating real bread we're eating
stuff with all the sugar in it and all
these additives and when you just make
straight up bread it's not bad for you
it's just flour water salt and yeast and
we get we eat bread all the time and you
know no one's you know I'm a little fat
but not really yeah
my wife's now you should hold my flour
too just flour and water and that's
about it yeah baking powder a little
baking powder that's what my grandmother
why don't you show in how to make
tortillas why don't you mind your own
business so
but you know
instead of leaving me things that I
could do to remind me of her she took
them with her
and I tried to make beans one time I
didn't realize half a pound is nine
pounds of [ __ ] beans they come out of
the boiling out of the water the clothes
are in there the [ __ ] is still find them
I'll see the dogs [ __ ] around with
something we gotta [ __ ] beans four
years ago they just like they just grow
and keep growing they just kept coming
out of them
but what I'd like to be able to make
tortillas the way my grandmother made
them yeah if I look back and think maybe
I could assemble the thoughts of what
she the baking soda and the yeah with
the water and the way that she did it
and put the baking soda in there and
then you could do it maybe my wife could
do it and she rolls them because that
that's that's in and of itself yeah
rolling them out to get a nice Circle
yeah I just got delivered uh two days
ago a 10 inch tortilla press yeah put
that there now they're all done I just
put them on the commodity see what I
mean he's living some life
when I went to Carrillo Zoo this place
is still open and when I was like seven
years old they were walking all the
ladies would be making the corn
tortillas and they would have a little
thing and they'd go like this
yeah and I would pretend I was waving
like they were clapping for my grandma
okay
thanks for coming in man thanks for
having me yeah it's great I hope that it
was really cool casual conversation yeah
it's very cool but it's also great to
sit down with you yeah for sure talk to
you man you're a great person uh you
know we don't really get a chance to
talk much when I see you yeah but you
you are everything that I thought you
would be oh thanks man I appreciate it I
was thinking about that on the way here
it's like we were always kind of running
into each other to see each other we
never really sit and talk and this was I
appreciate you man
yeah Dad and a husband and all that
thank you
Aaron today was a good day
all right thank you because he got a
jersey thanks for watching aside from
the Jersey aside from the Jersey was it
a good day we're talking about crying
he's been crying back then
I mean he was reading he's reading
everything that was all written on that
number five it's like geez Albert
he did it yeah that's amazing